me llamo tales steiner ya conocí a
algunos de ustedes en el otro salón
estoy aquí como profesor asociado
trabajando para khan academy voy a
compartirles mi experiencia contarles un
poco de cómo conseguir las computadoras
y por qué lo hice lo que hice con ellas
y después voy a responder cualquier
pregunta que tengan y también tendremos
tiempo más en la tarde pueden acercarse
y preguntarme lo que sea entonces
rápidamente esa es una foto muy
halagadora de mí y estas imágenes son
para recordarme de qué hablar la primera
es la campana de la libertad yo di
clases en filadelfia dos años en una
escuela al noreste de filadelfia esto de
aquí es una pequeña advertencia quiero
decirles que yo no estoy aquí porque sea
el maestro del año ni mucho menos solo
quiero compartirles mi experiencia con
khan academy he tenido experiencia con
eso y con otros profesores entonces me
da gusto compartir mi propia experiencia
y lo que he aprendido de otros
profesores en términos de buenas
prácticas pero de ninguna manera está
diciendo que sea un gran maestro
transmitiendo sabiduría
sólo quería aclarar eso de aquel lado un
pequeño carrete de cine
porque cuando termine de hablar en unos
a 10 minutos voy a proyectar un pequeño
vídeo sobre mi salón de clases
espero no revelar demasiado yo amo ti
eso es solo porque me encanta a ti está
en el fondo de la otra foto y por eso la
elegí finalmente este reloj con símbolos
matemáticos lo encontré en google pero
es para representar el hecho de que
todas estas discusiones y testimonios de
profesores como sony o yo o gente en el
sitio hablando de lo bueno que es khan
academy todas esas cosas buenas que
pueden pasar solo quiero decir que estas
cosas maravillosas de las que hablamos
no pasaron el primer día que usamos khan
academy hubo un proceso de prueba y
error que estoy seguro de que cualquiera
que sea profesor sabe cómo es una gran
parte del proceso fue arriesgarnos
intentar nuevas ideas muchas de ellas no
funcionaron y así pudimos ver cuáles sí
además los estudiantes siempre te jalan
hacia direcciones que tú no te esperas
solo quería decir eso
entonces los temas que yo quería abordar
el señor filadelfia por dos años y
después del primero me daba cuenta de
que había una enorme diferencia entre
algunos de los alumnos algunos de los
chicos estaban muy avanzados y otros muy
atrasados y yo me di cuenta de que iba a
ser imposible alcanzarlos a todos por
igual
lo que me frustraba era que si quería
diferenciar iba a ser demasiado trabajo
de mi parte y eso era insostenible por
más que yo quisiera por otro lado y de
manera relacionada había enormes
problemas de conducta en la clase y me
di cuenta de que mucho de ello tenía que
ver con que los alumnos más atrasados no
estaban aprendiendo se frustraban se
avergonzaban mientras que los más
adelantados se aburrían y no era un reto
para ellos entonces tanto a nivel de
contenido como el de conducta realmente
quería corregir eso y por último la
falta de tecnología a mí me gusta mucho
usarla y me parecía muy extraño que en
un salón de clases en el siglo 21 no
hubiera ni una computadora y si yo daba
clases en un distrito donde los recursos
son un poco más limitados que los que
algunos de ustedes dan clases al menos
he hablado con algunos que vienen de
distritos donde si hay mucha tecnología
y están buscando cómo utilizarla y otros
que necesitan salir y conseguir sus
propios recursos
mis computadoras de hecho fue
relativamente fácil de conseguirlas
durante el verano me dediqué a conseguir
unas computadoras encontré una
organización sin fines de lucro que
vende computadoras usadas cada una me
costó 100 dólares y me pasé dos tardes
llamando a amigos y familiares y
preguntándoles si querían patrocinar una
o la mitad o un cuarto y pude recaudar
el dinero en poco tiempo a lo que voy es
que no digo que sea muy muy fácil de
lograr pero se puede hacer y mucha gente
aporta el dinero con gusto para esto así
que si ustedes se encuentran en la
situación de tratar de recaudar dinero
con gusto podemos hablar de eso después
mi implementación desde el primer
momento lo primero que quise hacer fue
asegurarme de atacar tanto alumnos de
nivel bajo como a nivel alto
así que imprimí lo que llaman listas de
reproducción yo solo las llamaba listas
temáticas tenía a los de 3º de prepa y
algunos de ellos batallaban mucho con
tablas de multiplicación porcentajes
cosas de ese tipo y realmente quería que
antes de graduarse tuvieran estos
fundamentos muy sólidos así que arme
unas listas y me senté a practicar con
ellos uno por uno y les dije si el
trabajo en la clase es muy difícil
puedes decirme e ir a trabajar en la
computadora como una cosa aparte y para
los más avanzados también fue muy bueno
hice una lista y dejé algunos espacios
en blanco para que ellos eligieran
algunos temas que querían trabajar y les
dije que si terminaban temprano su
trabajo podían ir a la computadora esa
fue la primera forma como empecé con
khan academy se los recomiendo mucho si
solo quieren usarlo un poco en el salón
pues a medida que me familiarizaba me di
cuenta de que todos mis alumnos podían
beneficiarse no solo los atrasados y
avanzados así que empecé a hacer una
lista completa por unidad y esas también
las clasifique como nivel 1 2 y 3 los
avanzados estaban más hacia el 2 o 3 los
que les costaba trabajo hacían más bien
nivel 1 y 2
me puse yo me puse a hacer mis propias
listas pero ahora va a haber una función
que es recomendaciones para profesores
que creo que va a ser muy bueno
les pueden dar una serie de temas a toda
la clase y luego tener unos adicionales
para los avanzados y otros también
adicionales para los más atrasados al
principio lo hice con los estudiantes de
nivel alto y los de nivel bajo luego
hice mitad y mitad es decir que la mitad
del grupo trabajaba conmigo la otra
mitad con las computadoras conmigo
trabajábamos en proyectos material
adicional remediar problemas y en las
computadoras trabajaban en temas que
eran específicos a sus necesidades puse
todas las pantallas viendo hacia mí así
que si alguien se distraía yo podía
verlo desde el otro lado del salón y eso
siempre era muy divertido y lo último
eran las rotaciones y estos se los
recomiendo mucho si tienen un grupo con
conducta un poco mejor había gente en
las computadoras otros conmigo y otros
que estaban trabajando
independientemente
me refiero a que era independiente del
profesor pero podría ser en equipos o
individualmente con el libro de texto o
un proyecto o lo que fuera está de hecho
era mi forma favorita de dirigir la
clase y realmente sentía que los alumnos
se apropiaban de la clase cuando
hacíamos eso bien voy a continuar para
que podamos ver el vídeo algunos
resultados notables y también hay una
sección en su carpeta una página sobre
sony y yo no recuerdo cómo se llama la
sección pero planea tu clase planea tu
clase bien algunos resultados que obtuve
fueron diferenciación claro como lo
mencioné pude trabajar con alumnos de
nivel alto y bajo íconos de nivel medio
en lugar de sólo enseñar para el
promedio del grupo como hacemos a veces
problemas de conducta esto fue muy
notable cómo se redujeron en la clase en
especial con los de nivel bajo y alto
también hice un calendario por bloques
lo que puede ser muy bueno porque
abarcan mucho contenido haces muchas
cosas pero se han enseñado así sabrán
que eso también implica tenerlos
concentrados por periodos largos lo que
puede ser doloroso a veces y cuando
haces estas actividades de rotación los
chicos realmente mantienen mejor la
concentración
atención del profesor si tenía unos
alumnos en las computadoras concentrados
la proporción de alumnos que se dirigían
al profesor incrementaba
significativamente y no disminuía para
mí es confianza para los alumnos esto
era evidente más que nada en el caso de
los alumnos de nivel bajo
tenía alumnos que me decían no he
aprendido nada de matemáticas en 5 años
y les emocionaba mucho aprender habían
estado haciendo sólo lo necesario para
pasar la materia y estaban empezando a
interesarse por las matemáticas y hacer
lo que tenían que hacer en lugar de solo
hacer hacer como que entendían y pasar y
finalmente interés y apropiación creo
que ya toque el tema pero lo que
realmente me gusta remarcar es que los
chicos de verdad se involucraban en su
aprendizaje tenían el temario frente a
ellos y veían lo que habían logrado
competían entre ellos y así se
impulsaban unos a otros y a sí mismos y
era muy divertido verlo
en vídeo de cinco minutos
me llamo steiner y este es mi segundo
año enseñando en la escuela pública de
la escuela omni una escuela con fondos
públicos que a partir de este año es
administrada por aspira en un esfuerzo
por mejorar sus condiciones la escuela
al noreste de filadelfia ha estado en la
lista de las de más bajo nivel por
varios años y tiene algunos de los
resultados académicos más bajos de la
ciudad
este año tengo el privilegio de enseñar
matemáticas en el último grado para
cuando llegan al último año hay un
amplio rango de habilidades algunos de
ellos van a ir a la universidad y tienen
un nivel alto de matemáticas otros están
batallando con tablas de multiplicar
tener a tantos alumnos diferentes con
diversos niveles de conocimiento
provocaba muchos problemas en el salón
para atender las necesidades de todos
los alumnos hay veces que siento que
estoy corriendo en un maratón al tratar
de llegar de un alumno a otro me
encantaría poder darles a los alumnos la
atención personal que necesitan no me
gusta que los demás entiendan el tema
antes que yo
si no entiendo lo que pasa en clase me
pongo a distraer a los otros si no hago
mi trabajo
solo distraigo a los demás si el tema es
muy difícil y el profesor no viene a
ayudarme agachó la cabeza y me duermo me
rindo
me molesta cuando yo quiero aprender
algo nuevo y no podemos tenemos que
repasar cosas una y otra vez lo que
comenzó a frustrarme muy pronto era que
fuera de la escuela los alumnos viven en
un mundo acelerado en el que siempre
están en el celular o en internet o
jugando mientras que en el salón quieren
que dé clases con un modelo del siglo 19
con el profesor dando cátedra al frente
y un objetivo en el pizarrón para todos
los alumnos
estuve mucho tiempo pensando en cómo
introducir la tecnología en mi salón y
cómo asegurarme de que tanto los alumnos
avanzados como los atrasados aprendieran
me propuse conseguir computadoras para
mi salón sabía que si la pasaba bien
podía beneficiar a mis alumnos y
ayudarme mucho amigo encontré una
organización que me vendió 10
computadoras usadas a 100 dólares cada
una y con la ayuda de algunos amigos y
familiares pude recaudar el dinero para
pagarlas
desde el principio tanto a mis alumnos
como a mí nos encantó el programa gratis
en línea khan academy ellos podían
trabajar individualmente en temas de su
propio nivel practicando con ejercicios
interactivos viendo vídeos y me permitía
a mí monitorear fácilmente su avance
una vez que encontré varias maneras de
implementar khan academy el cambio en mi
salón fue extraordinario
khan academy ha hecho que la clase está
enfocada en los alumnos la oportunidad
de diferenciar ha hecho que los alumnos
tengan mayor confianza en sí mismos y
mayor entusiasmo por aprender
me gusta tener varios temas de donde
elegir porque puedo ver lo que ha
logrado
el maestro viene y tiene como 30 alumnos
más en la clase así que no puede
ayudarme enseguida pero la computadora
me da información inmediata si estás con
un problema y lo tienes mal te lo dice
de inmediato y luego te lo explica
ahora uso las computadoras todos los
días puedo agrupar a los alumnos por
nivel de habilidad o por estilo de
aprendizaje
khan academy no solo ayuda para
fortalecer los conocimientos de los
alumnos sino que me permite enfocarme y
trabajar con grupos pequeños
además del hecho de que los alumnos
pueden trabajar a su propio ritmo la
conducta en el salón ha mejorado
notablemente ahora puedo enfocar mi
energía en enseñar en lugar de corregir
conducta quita muchas distracciones la
clase es más tranquila los alumnos se
emocionan con los ejercicios y sus
logros y como es de esperarse disfrutan
un poco de competencia saludable estás
mal no es cierto
ya lo entendí bien una estrella
sabes que cállate siendo el mejor
me siento solo allá arriba
la puntuación lo dice todo y ni siquiera
está actualizada
no digo que khan academy haya resuelto
todos los problemas de la educación
urbana ni mucho menos que los profesores
sean obsoletos pero la verdad es que con
algunas computadoras baratas y este
increíble programa gratuito mi salón de
clases se transformó radicalmente y los
alumnos han aprendido más gracias khan
academy
a domicilio
exista
tuve más ingresos
ah
hoy
sí
y